RICHARD HAASS: Well, good evening.
Welcome to the Council on Foreign Relations.
I'm Richard Haass, the president of this organization,
and I want to thank all of you, whether here
in person or watching us through one or another
technology, for joining for us for tonight's
Sorensen Distinguished Lecture on the United
Nations.
Now, this is the first Sorensen Lecture since
Ted passed away in 2010, so what I'd like
to do for a minute is recognize some of his
contributions to this institution and to this
country.
He would often joke -- about many things -- (laughter)
-- but one of the things Ted would joke about
would -- is -- is on his epitaph, his name
would be misspelled -- (laughter) -- and that
it would simply say something to the effect
that he had been President John F. Kennedy's
speechwriter or alter ego or something along
those lines.
And to be fair, historians could perhaps be
forgiven for focusing on those years, because
Ted played such an important part of history
that was really critical not just for this
country but for the world.
But that said, we here at the Council on Foreign
Relations and beyond know that there was more
to his career and much more to him than that.
In his many speaking appearances here at the
Council on Foreign Relations over the decade
covered not just issues like the Cold War
but also topics as varied as trade with Africa,
peace in the Middle East, and my personal
favorite, conflict resolution and political
reform in Tajikistan.
(Laughter.)
It was a veritable barn burner.
I want to thank his wife, whose here with
us tonight, Gillian, for her part in the establishment
of this -- of this lecture series, and more
broadly, being so generous with Ted's time
over the years.
We must have seemed like competition, I expect,
every now and then.
Ted was good enough to serve on the board
of this organization and was really a central
part of our intellectual community.
He was also someone, and perhaps the only
person I know, who had the creativity and
the courage to describe Pete Peterson, who
at that point was the chairman of the board
of directors, as a self-made man who worships
his own creator.
(Laughter.)
I know that Ted would have been delighted
to welcome tonight's speaker.
Ban Ki-moon is the eighth secretary-general
of the United Nations, and he's led that institution
-- just several blocks to the east, in case
you were wondering -- since 2007, and he's
worked hard, to say the least, to highlight
the importance of international action on
challenges ranging from climate change to
food security to poverty to conflict resolution.
And he's done this at a time, I would say,
of unusual challenge for this organization
and for the world.
It's all taken place against the backdrop
of global economic difficulty.
We've also seen the truly historic upheavals
throughout the Middle East, including but
not limited to revolutionary change in Egypt
and several other countries, a terrible civil
war in Syria, and Iran's steady march toward
developing the capacity to produce nuclear
weapons.
And then beyond the Middle East, a lot else
has been going on, from the movement, if you
will, of historical tectonic plates in Asia
and the Asia-Pacific region, which pose new
challenges to regional and potentially global
stability.
And then there's been the structural issue
at the same time of integrating many of the
world's new powers, from China to India to
Brazil and others into the institutions of
global governance, including the U.N., that
deal with issues ranging from climate change
to trafficking in drugs and persons.
In short, he has one of the world's most demanding
and most important inboxes.
What we are going to do tonight -- and we
are fortunate indeed -- is to hear the secretary-general
give -- make some opening remarks.
Then he will show considerable bravery of
his own by being joined onstage by Christiane
Amanpour, one of the country's and the world's
premiere journalists associated with both
CNN and ABC.
And they will have a short conversation, and
then he has agreed to open himself up to the
questions of our membership who are with us
tonight.
So ladies and gentlemen, please join me in
welcoming the secretary-general of the United
Nations.
(Applause.)
SECRETARY-GENERAL BAN KI-MOON: Thank you,
Dr. Richard Haass, president of the Council
on Foreign Relations, my good friend, Gillian
Sorensen, Ms. Christiane Amanpour of CNN,
distinguished guests, ladies and gentlemen.
It's a great pleasure to be here with you
today to share some of our thoughts about
the current international world, and I am
very much moved by your warm welcome.
Standing in this Council on Foreign Relations
today -- when it comes to timing of my speech
today, I think my appearance tonight seems
to be sandwiched by two big events.
Yesterday there was the Grammy awards -- (laughter)
-- tomorrow, most importantly, the President
Obama is going to have his union address -- State
of the Union address.
So I am sandwiched.
Of course, you know, I know I should not try
to compete with President Obama.
I don't have any such intention or ambition.
Perhaps I am luckier than President Obama,
at least in one sense: this -- I am not belonging
to either Democrats or Republican.
You can feel free to applaud together in this
hall -- (laughter) -- whatever I may say,
if you agree.
And as for the Grammy awards, I know you are
broadcasting this event this evening, but
I will not try to be a South Korean YouTube
sensation.
(Laughter.)
I promise you that no "Gangnam Style" for
me today.
(Laughter.)
In any event, thank you very much, again.
I am especially honored to deliver this Sorensen
lecture on the United Nations.
The Sorensen commitment to the principles
and goals of the United Nations is unrivaled.
Ted Sorensen wore U.N. blue helmet since the
model UNESCO exercise he took part in as a
student.
His law practice found many ways to advance
U.N. causes.
Gillian Sorensen, your voice has reached across
this country and around the world.
For decades now you have been a great U.N.
advocate, explaining what we do and why it
matters.
I know how much it pains you and Ted when
the United Nations was marginalized or misunderstood
-- not much appreciated.
This annual lecture has helped to serve as
a welcome corrective.
You may all be aware that my own career was
started in diplomacy when I was a -- as a
young high school student when I was lucky
enough to have met -- to meet the president,
John F. Kennedy, in 1962.
One minute at the time, I was just a very
poor rural boy visiting from war-torn South
Korea.
The next, standing there in the Rose Garden
in 1962.
I was determined and inspired to do my own
role to do for my country and leader, if possible,
to work for the world.
That is what I'm here.
I have wondered about Ted Sorensen's whereabouts
at the time.
Was he either watching us or more likely -- most
likely he must have been bent in on a typewriter,
wrestling another historic, memorable phrase
into being.
And, anyway, whatever the case may be, I feel
fortunate that my life has been touched by
the Sorensens' spirit of service.
Ladies and gentlemen, you all know how many
issues are on the United Nations' agenda.
I cannot possibly cover all of the issues
which is now being addressed by the United
Nations by myself, and by very, very dedicated
U.N. staff in this very limited time.
Therefore, I have done what is typically a
very dangerous thing for a U.N. secretary-general
to do.
I have chosen just two items above all others
to discuss in depth.
These two items both have huge consequences
for humanity.
In both cases, the international community
is not upholding its responsibility.
Both risk harsh judgment of history should
current trends continue, and both require
collective action that must involve the United
Nations.
What are those two issues?
I speak about the crisis in Syria and the
threat of climate change.
We can use the question-and-answer session
to cover other issues, like situations in
Mali, Afghanistan, Democratic Republic of
Congo or Democratic People's Republic of Korea
-- just a few.
But for me at this time, Syria and climate
deserve our heightened attention.
Ladies and gentlemen, Syria is self-destructing.
After nearly two years, we no longer count
-- we no longer count days in hours but in
bodies.
Another day, another hundred, 200 or 300 are
dead.
Fighting rages; sectarian hatred is on the
rise.
The catastrophe -- the catalogue of war crimes
is mounting.
Sexual violence is widespread.
The destruction is systematic.
Syria is being torn apart limb by limb.
The political crisis has spread a humanitarian
emergency.
Four million people -- that's 20 percent of
total population of Syria -- 1-out-of-5 are
in need of immediate humanitarian assistance.
Three-quarters of a million have fled the
country, straining Syria's neighbors and further
risking regional instability.
The pledges from the donor conference two
weeks ago, which I convened in Kuwait, will
help us to bring comfort to those in need.
But it can never be enough, however, to treat
the symptoms of conflict.
Our responsibility is to get to the roots
and make the violence stop before the moment
divides rules the day inside Syria, in the
region and the United Nations Security Council.
The Syrians are not ready to talk to one another.
The regime remains as repressive as ever.
The situation cries out for action by the
Security Council, in particular.
As Joint Special Representative Dr. Brahimi
has said, the council cannot simply wait for
divisions to evaporate.
That guarantees not only more violence, but
the very disintegration of the country and
the possibility that Syria could become an
arena for competing national and regional
forces, government and non-state actors alike.
The Security Council must no longer stand
on the sidelines, deadlocked, silently witnessing
the slaughter.
It must be willing, at long last, to come
together and establish the parameters for
the democratic transition that can save Syria.
The offer by national coalition leader, Moaz
al-Khatib to open discussions with representatives
of the Syrian government is an opportunity
they should not miss -- a chance to switch
from a devastating military logic to a promising
political approach.
This was a courageous offer by Mr. al-Khatib.
I urge both Syrian government and the Security
Council to respond positively.
We need to find a way towards negotiations
between empowered government and opposition
delegations that can made key decisions about
the country's future -- on elections, on constitutional
reform, on accountability for victims of international
crimes, on other steps needed to meet the
people's legitimate aspirations.
It is time for a clean break from Syria's
past and for a decisive turn toward a future
where Syrians are able to express their political
views freely, without fear of arbitrary arrest
or killing -- a Syria where human rights of
all are protected.
Let us also draw a broader lesson.
In the Arab world and elsewhere, people want
real change, not grudging, cosmetic adjustment.
Let us remember that whether countries are
emerging from conflict or authoritarian rule,
transition will not be linear marches toward
Jeffersonian democracy or Swiss-style tranquility.
The road will be rocky.
The cases of Myanmar, Timor-Leste and Sierra
Leon give some hope that patient, long-term
engagement, consistent diplomacy can yield
results.
The case of Mali shows how little we sometimes
understand about the fragility of democracies
considered well- established.
We must also resist the temptation to see
the current troubles in Egypt or Libya as
proof that the old order was a better one.
We can take some confidence from history that
period of -- periods of post- revolutionary
disorder are passing phenomena.
But close and patient engagement will be crucial.
The international community has a duty to
accompany these transitions with meaningful
contributions.
Ladies and gentlemen, let me now turn to the
gathering threat of climate change.
Scientists have long sounded the alarm.
Top-ranking military commanders and security
experts have now joined the chorus.
Yet, the political class seems far behind.
You all know the potential consequences: the
downward global spiral of extreme weather
and disaster, reversals in development gains,
increases in displacement, aggravated tensions
over water and land, fragile states tipping
into chaos.
Yet, greenhouse emissions are rising faster
than ever.
Business as usual retains its hold.
We must limit global temperature rise to two
degrees centigrade.
We are far from there, and even that is enough
to cause dire consequences.
If we continue along the current path, we
are close to a six degree increase.
That will be a catastrophe.
Too many leaders seem content to keep climate
change at arms' length and in a policy silo.
To few grasp the need to bring the threat
to the center of global security, economic
and financial management.
It's time to move beyond spending enormous
sums addressing the damage and to make investments
that will repay themselves many times over.
Some countries are embracing the transition
to low-carbon, low-emissions future.
They are adding electrical capacity through
renewable energy and avoiding the need to
build new coal power plants.
The renewable energy industry created 1.5
million new jobs last year.
The cost of wind power continued to fall.
With the right enabling public policies, close
to 80 percent of the world's energy supply
could be met by renewables by mid-century.
This is not utopian or science fiction.
It is current fact.
My sustainable energy for all initiative aims
to support and expand such a point.
The green economy is an essential insurance
policy and investment in a safer future for
all.
A global climate change agreement would give
us the engine we need to advance us decisively
on this path.
I welcome President Obama's due resolve to
address climate change and give it high political
priority.
I'm reaching out to government and business
leaders to mobilize the capital and the political
will for a global, legally binding climate
change treaty by 2015.
World leaders have pledged to reach an agreement
and we must hold them to that promise.
Ladies and gentlemen, before making my way
to Christiane Amanpour and your questions,
let me violate my own rule, which I said only
two items -- mention two other issues of special
urgency.
First, the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
There's a change in the air across the Middle
East.
It's long past time to resolve this conflict.
We all know that a just and a permanent solution
looks like.
In the years ahead, we must stop finding excuses
as to why the issues are too hard.
Second, situations on the Korean peninsula.
I have urged the new leadership of Pyongyang
to refrain from any further provocative actions,
particularly another nuclear test.
It is time for the DPRK authorities, who see
the unified call of the international community,
to return to dialogue for the denuclearization
of the Korean peninsula.
They should also address international concerns,
including about the dire humanitarian and
human rights situations.
Should they reverse course, both are open
for the DPRK to build a better future.
As the secretary-general of the United Nations,
I stand ready to work with all concerned parties
for peace and stability in the region.
On the more general question of disarmament
-- here, too -- I welcome President Obama's
heightened attention, including a push to
reduce nuclear arsenals.
On my part, I continue to press for steps
to realize the goals of the five-point plan
I set out early in my first term.
Later this week, Wednesday and Thursday, I
will visit Washington, D.C. for talks on these
and many other issues.
I look forward to my discussions on Capitol
Hill and with the secretary of state John
Kerry.
My task as the secretary-general is to address
crises today while building solid foundations
for tomorrow.
I seek good international formulas.
I try to make possible the sacrifices and
compromises that may be painful in the moment
but which bring great dividends for coming
generations.
We live in an age of monumental transitions
-- economic, demographic, political.
Global interdependencies are deepening; transitional
threats are growing.
This means we must make better use of the
United Nations machinery.
From peacekeeping and peace- building, from
prevention to international criminal justice,
our tools have proven more dynamic than most
people give us credit for.
But we also recognize the need for our vehicle,
first created in the 1940s, to be equipped
for the highways of the 21st century.
International machinery does not operate on
its own.
Hardware requires programmers.
We need national leaders to think globally.
We need a stronger sense of collective responsibility.
And we need the United States, "our last best
hope," I quote.
That is how President Kennedy, with help from
Ted Sorensen, famously described the United
Nations in his inaugural address.
He was speaking about a world in the grip
of an arms race.
Now today we face a race against time.
I look forward to the contributions that you
in this room will make towards helping us
reach our shared destinations: a safer, more
just and more sustainable world for all.
I thank you for your attention.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
CHRISTIANE AMANPOUR (chief international correspondent,
CNN): So without further ado, because I know
we're all on a schedule, I'm going to speak
to the secretary-general further for about
10 minutes, and then we're going to open it
up to the members for questions.
So, Mr. Secretary-General, when you've got
your papers sorted out, you've said that,
you know, often you worry that the U.N. has
been marginalized and that people complain
about that.
You've spoken about how you don't measure
days and hours anymore when it comes to Syria,
but you measure them in bodies.
And you're talking about Syria being torn
limb from limb.
So has the United Nations failed?
Is this a failure of the international security
system?
BAN: I don't think the United Nations has
failed.
What I'm stressing is that the international
community must be united.
As I said, division rules the day.
Particularly, the Security Council members
should feel a collective responsibility for
the humanity and for the history.
How can they answer after many years after
this crisis is over?
And whether they have done all what they should
have done, I as the secretary-general don't
want to apologize to the international community
after many years for what I and we could have
done for humanity.
This is my message.
For that -- first of all, Syrians, both parties,
they must stop killing each other, and they
must sit together.
Now there is a small window of opportunity
for both opposition forces and even government.
AMANPOUR: Does your special representative,
the joint envoy Lakhdar Brahimi, believe that
there's a real opportunity for talks right
now?
You mentioned Mouaz al-Khatib, the opposition
leader, has offered to meet the members of
the Assad regime, and in fact the Assad regime
has also said that it would like to hold talks
as well, but there are lot of conditions attached
by both sides.
Do you honestly believe that there is a chance
for talks?
BAN: If there is a political will, commitment,
for humanity, there is a chance.
Today I had a long talk with -- again, over
telephone -- with Lakhdar Brahimi.
We discuss with him everything -- either myself,
my deputy secretary-general or Jeffrey Feltman,
the head of the political department.
We always discuss.
And he met Moaz al-Khatib yesterday in Cairo,
and they discussed all this political transition.
I think they are ready.
And even if opposition forces are now ready
to talk with all the parties concerned, including
even regime, for whom they rejected to meet,
and they asked us in the past that their condition
was that President Assad should step down
before --
AMANPOUR: Their condition now --
BAN: Yes.
AMANPOUR: Their condition now is to release
all the political prisoners.
BAN: Yes, I have been urging Syrian authorities,
and I have conveyed my message to President
Assad that he should do whatever he can to
create an atmosphere conducive for dialogue
for political transition in releasing all
these prisoners -- and particularly women
detained for political reasons.
AMANPOUR: This has been going on for nearly
two years, and you've expressed frustration
quite regularly.
When I interviewed you last, I asked you what
is Plan B, and you said there is no Plan B.
Now you've just talked about a collective
responsibility.
Well, the United Nations adopted a responsibility
to protect.
Has it failed in Syria?
BAN: We have seen some good examples when
it comes to responsibility to protect.
Now, this is a principle agreed upon and committed
by all the world's leaders in 2005, and the
member states of the General Assembly have
been discussing this matter, how to operationalize
this very important principle.
We have seen good successes in case of Cote
d'Ivoire and Libya --
AMANPOUR: Yeah, but in Syria.
BAN: -- but Syria, it has not been applied.
It has not --
AMANPOUR: Well, right -
BAN: It's been able to work.
AMANPOUR: So has it failed?
BAN: We are not working for failure.
We are working for success.
(Laughter.)
AMANPOUR: I know you're working for success.
Would you say it's a success, then?
BAN: No.
We have yet to work very hard -- (audio break)
-- we have to work very hard.
That's why I'm asking world leaders, whether
they are in Syria or -- (audio break) -- region,
Security Council -- they have to be united.
They have to have a sense of responsibility
for humanity, for the future, for -- (audio
break).
AMANPOUR: As they were leaving the administration,
Secretary of Defense Leon Panetta, CIA Director
-- former -- David Petraeus, outgoing Secretary
of State Hillary Clinton said that they all
supported the idea of arming and training
the rebels.
Do you think that diplomacy can work -- the
best efforts of Lakhdar Brahimi -- if it is
not backed up by the use of force or the threat
of the use of force?
In Syria I'm talking about.
BAN: Basically at this point -- and I have
been urging both parties -- (audio break).
AMANPOUR: Was it being recorded or it's just
not on the -- on the loudspeaker?
(Audio break.)
(Off-side conversation.)
AMANPOUR: Live television.
BAN: This is live?
(Laughter.)
AMANPOUR: It is.
It's being streamed.
It's being streamed, but don't worry.
(Laughter.)
OK, I will -- just to sort of -- (inaudible).
So, in other words, as you -- as you seek
-- as you seek to try to have your envoys
accomplish some diplomacy, would it be much
easier if it was backed up by the use of force?
BAN: Basically, there is no military options.
There is no military solution.
Unfortunately, both sides seem to believe
determinedly that they can win over the other
by military means.
But that's wrong approach.
All the pending issues should have been -- should
be resolved through a political dialogue.
In the end, it's a political transition.
I have been urging all the countries who may
be providing arms to both sides -- they should
stop.
Now, they -- both sides must stop the fighting
each other.
AMANPOUR: You know, look, that would be great,
but it's just not going to happen until there's
some kind of tipping point.
And I was speaking to Senator McCain today,
who said that all the reasons for not intervening
have now come true because of not intervening.
In other words, the idea that one would create
a space for jihadis if one intervened, they're
already there by not intervening.
The idea that it would spill over into the
region by intervening has already happened
by not intervening.
So I know that you don't appreciate or want
the use of force, but how do you think this
is going to stop?
I mean, really?
BAN: That's what Lakhdar Brahimi -- and we
are working very hard to talk with the parties
concerned, Russia, United States and members
of the permanent -- permanent members of the
Security Council.
They should have a primary responsibility.
And Lakhdar Brahimi has been meeting all the
parties in the region, and including Security
Council members.
Let diplomacy, let dialogue prevail over military
means.
That's the best way and most practical way
to save for human lives.
AMANPOUR: As you mentioned, there are some
4 million Syrians in need of help inside Syria.
There's about three-quarters of a million
who have crossed the borders.
One of your senior U.N. officials told me
the other day that it's very possible that
some of the neighbors may slam the doors on
these refugees.
They're drowning in refugees.
It's affecting their own stability.
They can't cope.
Is that a worry, or do you think all this
money that you've gotten pledged in Kuwait
is going to help?
BAN: I'm extremely concerned about the current
situation when it comes to humanitarian situation.
In the absence of a political solution, the
United Nations has been mobilizing all possible
agencies and resources.
That's why I decided to convene an international
high-level donors conference, where the member
states have generously contributed more than
$1.5 billion.
But this is for up to only June, end of June.
The number of refugees are increasing day-by-day.
Sometimes more than 3,000 people cross the
border overnight, through Jordan, Iraq, Lebanon
and Turkey.
It's almost impossible to handle all these
refugees.
The total number is almost reaching 800,000
as of today, and there are 4 million people
affected.
And this is 2.5 million people internally
displaced.
AMANPOUR: Do you worry that countries like
Jordan will just say enough, we can't have
anymore?
BAN: I visited the Zaatari camp in Jordan
and also camp -- a refugee camp in Turkey.
My message has been consistent: Please keep
your border open.
There were some cases that they were returning
these refugees, but I am urging them to keep
this refugee flow.
Whenever, wherever they want to find a place,
they should be accommodated.
The United Nations will do our best efforts
to provide humanitarian assistance.
AMANPOUR: Let's move on to North Korea.
You said that you had urged the leaders of
North Korea not to conduct another nuclear
test.
Who have you spoken to and what has the response
been?
BAN: Most of all I've been using my public
statement as the secretary-general of the
United Nations, and the messages have been
conveyed to Pyongyang through the major countries
in the -- in the region.
AMANPOUR: So you haven't picked up the phone
and talked --
BAN: I have not been able to talk directly
to leadership in Pyongyang.
They don't work in that way.
(Laughter.)
I don't think whether anybody has ever spoken
over the telephone to North Korean leadership.
That's what they do.
So sometimes it's very, very difficult.
AMANPOUR: So what will the new president of
South Korea -- what will the new president
of South Korea be able to do?
She's already spoken about wanting to change,
to an extent, the policy of her predecessor.
BAN: She has a very good practical vision
in this Korean Peninsula confidence and trust
process.
She met former leader Kim Jong Il in 2002.
And I think that she's in a better position
to really break this deadlocked situation
on the Korean Peninsula.
Now, my mission has been that if DPRK conducts
nuclear tests at this time, unfortunately
it may effectively tie the hands of the new
president of Korea, that it may take a long
time before anybody can really be able to
think about the -- normalizing the relationship.
Therefore, I would urge again the DPRK authorities
to focus their priority on making their people
economically sustainable and developing of
people is more important at this time.
If they run the nuclear test, this not only
runs counter and violates the relevant Security
Council resolutions, but it's going toward
the wrong direction -- wrong direction.
AMANPOUR: You mentioned Mali.
The U.N. and the Security Council are in talks,
I think, about a potential peacekeeping force
for Mali.
Is that something that you can see happening?
Are the talks far along?
Will there be a U.N. peacekeeping force there?
BAN: I know that members of the Security Council
are discussing this matter.
And in fact, you know, I had some initial
discussions with the members of the Security
Council on this matter.
But the situation at this time is still very
precarious, very dangerous at this time.
But we need to assess the situation on the
ground before we will be able to discuss establishing
the U.N. peacekeeping operation.
AMANPOUR: Do you think it should happen?
BAN: I think it's a matter of time when the
-- these coalition forces will be able to
address the security concerns on the ground,
then we will be able to discuss this matter.
AMANPOUR: On a different issue in a different
country, you had a lot of U.N. and NGO humanitarian
medical workers trying to vaccinate populations
in Pakistan.
And they are being killed.
I mean, they are just being killed.
And some of these vaccination programs are
having to be suspended.
I mean, do you see any way out of that?
What is going on?
And have you had any conversations that lead
you to believe that that's something that's
going to stop or be reversed?
BAN: It is totally unacceptable that health
workers are being killed while vaccinating
polio in Pakistan, in Nigeria.
Unfortunately, again yesterday three more
Korean health workers, doctors, were killed
by these people.
And I have condemned them strong -- in the
strongest possible terms.
They are working selflessly for benefit of
people, for health of those young people to
eradicate the polio.
There are only three countries in the world
at this time where polio still exists -- that's
Afghanistan, Pakistan and Nigeria.
We are working very hard with the leaders
of those countries to eradicate once and for
all this polio.
AMANPOUR: If the violence doesn't stop, will
these programs be ended?
BAN: I think we will have to continue vaccinating
these people to save their children's lives.
Otherwise, they will be dying needlessly.
AMANPOUR: Secretary General, thank you very
much.
BAN: Thank you very much.
AMANPOUR: And now we're going to open it to
questions.
(Applause.)
So I have a couple of instructions here regarding
how to do the questions.
I think -- are there microphones?
Yes.
OK.
So I saw a hand over there first.
Right there, this gentleman.
Yeah, you got the mic there?
QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Dan Altman from NYU and North Yard Economics.
Mr. Secretary General, I'd like to ask you
about an area where you do have some real
leverage and not just moral suasion, which
is the running of the U.N. itself.
The U.N., despite its effectiveness in some
areas, which you mentioned, still has a reputation
for opaque administration, for hiring and
coddling perhaps incompetent workers and also
for perhaps wasting some money here and there,
though many governments and companies do that
as well.
And I would like to ask you: What can you
to do improve the transparency and accountability
of your organization, since those themes are
two things that you emphasize so much?
I can tell you, from my own experience, I've
been unable to figure how much, for example,
the --
AMANPOUR: Not too long, OK?
Not a speech.
QUESTIONER: There's a last sentence --
AMANPOUR: Not a speech.
And please, everybody, members, not a speech.
Otherwise, we don't get anywhere.
QUESTIONER: How much, for example, did the
Rio Plus 20 conference cost the U.N. as a
whole?
AMANPOUR: OK.
Thank you.
QUESTIONER: Maybe that's a good place to start.
AMANPOUR: Thank you.
BAN: First of all, improving efficiency by
enhancing transparency and accountability
has been one of my top priorities as a change
in management policy.
I think we have achieved a lot.
The United Nations is different from the past.
Of course in the past the United Nations must
have been working very hard to improve their
way of working.
But since I took over this responsibility,
from day one, the accountability, ethics,
high level of ethics, and transparency and
openness and accessibility have been some
keywords for my organization, and I'm going
to continue to do that.
You talk about the Rio Plus 20 summit meeting.
Again, we have achieved a lot.
For just one example, we had for the first
time to use this smart conference, the paperless
conference.
We used -- (off mic) -- some tens of thousands
-- like 30,000 pages are printed and distributed
to the member states.
Otherwise, it might have been millions of
pages.
In the recent Doha climate change conference
in December last year, we also reduced a lot
-- millions of pages of paper by using smart
paperless conference.
And this is what -- the United Nations is
trying to improve the way we work.
AMANPOUR: Over there.
Ken.
Ken Roth of Human Rights Watch.
And I know you know how to ask a question.
(Laughter.)
QUESTIONER: Mr. Secretary-General, I would
like to ask you about a particularly courageous
step you took in your first term in commissioning
the so-called Petrie report, which looked
very critically at the U.N.'s operations in
Sri Lanka in the waning months of the war
with Tamil Tigers and essentially criticized
the U.N. for prioritizing humanitarian presence
over speaking out over the indiscriminate
shelling and murder of 40,000.
There are two recommendations it makes that
I want to ask you for a progress report on.
One was the recommendation that a senior political
person be put in charge of any crisis like
that, so that the U.N.'s priorities were properly
reflected, and second, that there be a rapid
deployment of human rights monitors, to make
it contemporary, in a situation like Mali
or Syria.
Where does that stand?
BAN: Now I have decided, when it comes to
Mali, we didn't have any mission there.
With -- soon as this crisis began, within
one week I had dispatched and deployed on
the ground this high political mission.
And I deployed, in close consultation with
the high commissioner for human rights, more
humanitarian monitors on the ground.
We will try to increase more.
The -- protecting human rights and also humanitarian
assistance -- this is a top priority in all
the conflict zones, as we have been doing
in Sri Lanka and elsewhere.
And in that regard, I appreciate Mr. Ken Roth,
with whom I have been working very closely.
Your advice has been quite appreciated.
Thank you very much.
Thank --
AMANPOUR: Right here.
Can we get a microphone?
QUESTIONER: Felice Gaer.
Mr. Secretary-General, when you spoke here
in 2006, before you were elected, you said
that the responsibility to protect was one
of the issues that the -- I -- a top issue
for you, needed to be substantiated.
There is no one currently in the position
of special representative on responsibility
to protect.
Do you intend to fill that position?
BAN: I was here in May 2006.
In fact, at that time I was one of the candidates
for this job.
I'm lucky, you know, fortunate to be chosen
as the secretary-general to serve the United
Nations.
Today, this afternoon, I read -- I just particularly
went through what I said the last time, in
2006.
(Laughter.)
So you pointed out exactly what I said.
One of my campaign pledges at that time was
that if and when I would be elected the secretary-general,
I would do my best to operationalize the concept
of responsibility to protect.
I will continue to do that.
As you know, I appointed the special adviser
on responsibility to protect.
It has been quite difficult, how to give it
this level of comfort of member states on
this principle.
It has been quite a sensitive and patient
process.
But we have had the several rounds of General
Assembly discussions, and there was a consensus
resolutions.
We are moving, even though it's not moving
fast enough as we have been expecting, as
you may be expecting -- I think we are going
toward the right direction.
And at this time Mr. Deng, who worked as the
registrar of ICTR, International Criminal
Tribunal for Rwanda, is now working as a special
adviser on prevention of genocide and special
adviser for responsibility to protect.
But when the time comes, you know, I would
try to point -- separate the special adviser
on that.
Thank you.
QUESTIONER: Evelyn Leopold (sp).
You say you're going to Washington.
We happen to have a Congress that wants to
cut the budget.
The Republicans are not that happy with the
U.N. They will reflect some of the same criticism
that the first questioner had.
Whether it's true or not, they don't very
much like foreigners.
Aside from your -- aside from your trip, what
are you doing to promote the United Nations
in the United States?
BAN: I have been visiting Washington, D.C.,
and visiting and meeting the members of Congress,
both House of Representatives and Senate.
I'm going to have meetings with both the Foreign
Relations Committee in the Senate and in the
House of Representatives.
I believe that United Nations and United States
share same goals and objectives.
When U.N. was created, U.S. played a crucially
important role, in fact.
Therefore, we need the support of the United
States.
Twenty- two percent to 27 percent of U.N.
budget is being borne by the United States,
the largest contributor.
And on top of this assessed contribution,
U.S. pays a lot of extrabudgetary contributions
on development and human rights and security
and peace issues.
We are very much grateful.
That's why it's crucially important for any
secretary-general of the United Nations or
any staff of the United Nations to have strong
support of the United Nations -- United States.
That is why I always try to meet, starting
from president and secretary of state and
members of the Congress.
And I also want to get support from the citizens
of the United States.
That's why I've been traveling a lot around
the United States.
United Nations Association of U.N. and also
United States -- United Nations Association
of United States and also U.N. Foundation
-- they have been playing a great role to
help United Nations.
AMANPOUR: So before I take another one from
the floor, I need to ask you a question from
a national member.
It came over via email.
And this is from Nancy Aossey, International
Medical Corps.
She's in Santa Monica, California.
She wants to know, how do you envision the
U.N. better leveraging the impact of NGOs
to support the 4 million Syrians who we've
been talking about in need of help?
How are you planning to make that happen?
And what critical needs, she asked, are the
U.N. prioritizing?
BAN: Working together with the NGOs is crucially
important.
In case of Syria, we have very limited access.
We normally work together with Red Crescent
of Syria and International Red Cross Society,
ICRC, and International Red Cross Federation
-- Federation of Red Cross.
And many of the humanitarian-related agencies
and, you know, organizations, they provide
the generous -- (inaudible) -- generous resources.
They provide a lot of access.
They play very important role.
AMANPOUR: There are a lot of people in Syria
who are complaining now that they're not getting
the stuff that they need; they're cold, they're
hungry, they don't have enough medicine, despite
your best efforts.
What are you prioritizing?
BAN: There is a limit for the United Nations
at this time.
First of all, access program and the resources,
the -- OCHA has been organizing this one -- it's
a humanitarian coordinator -- together with
World Food Program.
United Nations High Commission for Refugees
and WHO and all other -- UNICEF, all other
humanitarian- related agencies are working
very, very hard in close consultation.
I myself chaired -- chairing -- (inaudible)
-- quite often to have coordinated and structured
way of delivering assistance.
QUESTIONER: (Inaudible.)
You have the tools to go to the Security Council
when it is a difficult situation, as it is
right now on Syria, (and it stopped).
You as secretary-general can actually convene
the council on a matter so grave, or the membership
of the General Assembly can go -- (inaudible)
-- for peace to the G-8 or General Assembly
and do something about it.
Is it time?
When will it be time for Syria to do that?
And why do you keep saying that there is no
need for Jeffersonian or Swiss-like democracy
in the Arab region.
In that way, aren't you just endorsing a mitigated
democracy?
Why not?
Why not demand that when they promised that
by election?
BAN: Primary responsibility is with -- rests
with the Security Council.
At the same time, General Assembly also held
several sessions to discuss the Syrian situation.
However, I believe that the Security Council
is fully aware of the importance and urgency
and seriousness of this issue, therefore I'm
urging always the Security Council should
take a collective and urgent responsibility
on this matter.
AMANPOUR: We have time for one last question.
You didn't -- you didn't finish your question
about why you don't believe they have the
right to Jeffersonian democracy.
BAN: Jeffersonian democracy is an ideal democracy,
most ideal.
But the Syrian people at this time, first
and foremost, they have to stop this fighting,
military fighting again.
AMANPOUR: One last question.
Yes, sir, your hand is up.
QUESTIONER: Michael Doyle, the chairman of
your U.N. Democracy Fund advisory board, from
Columbia University.
(Laughter.)
I have a question for you, Secretary-General.
Many people have come to the view that the
R2P route through the Security Council has
failed because of the stalemate in the council,
and therefore their suggestion, since it's
already been raised here, of a Plan B, which
is arming the rebels -- could you tell us
your concern about Plan B, arming the rebels
as a way to resolve the civil war in Syria?
BAN: I think from the beginning, this -- the
crisis began because of -- (inaudible) -- that
either side seem to have thought that they
would win and solve this problem through military
means.
The first began -- it began with the Syrians'
government.
When people were demonstrating, expressing
their genuine aspirations through free expression,
free will, then government repressed and responded
by killing people.
That both is counter -- (inaudible) -- response
by the opposition forces through violent means.
Therefore, I believe that continuing this
way, you cannot find any solution of this
Syrian crisis.
Therefore, without any condition, they must
stop this fighting and engage in dialogue.
That's the only viable solution at this time.
Just arming either side, opposition forces
and Syrian, by the country's concern, this
will only deteriorate the situation.
(Exhales.)
(Laughter.)
AMANPOUR: Thank you very much.
I mean, it's hard to know how it can get any
worse, but it can because it can go on and
on and on.
But let's hope that some sanity prevails at
some point.
Secretary-General, thank you very much indeed
for joining us and members of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
(Applause.)